395 c'est le nombre d'hommes encore
détenus à Guantanamo 5 ans après
l'ouverture de cette prison américaine
sur la base cubaine au nom de la guerre
contre le terrorisme les défenseurs des
droits de l'homme du monde entier
réclame toujours sa fermeture Mourad
Benchellali et français il y a passé
deux ans et demi et il témoigne des
mauvais traitements infligés aux
prisonniers Christophe Nardini avec nos
confrères de France 3 Lyon
et puis le sentiment d'être oublié aussi
comme lui ils sont plus de 700 à avoir
ces journées derrière les barbelés de ce
que l'on considère comme un des camps de
prisonniers les plus secrets du monde
400 personnes sont toujours détenues à
Guantanamo aucune charge précise ne pèse
contre elle et elles n'ont pas la
possibilité juridique de contester leur
détention
c'est aussi le camp le plus critique est
sur la planète
visite de leur famille ou d'un avocat de
leur choix sans jamais les poursuivre
pénalement tout en les torturant dans un
enclos devraient être rejeté de tout
pays civilisé dans le monde
en 5 ans 380 personnes ont été renvoyées
dans leur pays sans qu'aucune charge ne
soit retenue contre elle aujourd'hui
l'administration américaine affirme
vouloir fermer la prison dès que
possible sans avancer aucune date